c'est une ambiance d'apocalypse
qui pourtant ne refroidit pas les
habitants de longueuil arden en norvège
[Musique]
température ressentie en ce début
d'année - 24°
mais pour rien au monde il n'aurait
manqué le rendez vous le plus important
de l'année dans la petite ville le
premier jour où le soleil est de retour
dans la vallée après quatre mois de mi
polaire
vous savez la nuit polaire même si ça
peut être agréable c'est long alors pour
nous c'est important de célébrer le
retour du ciel les paysages vont être à
nouveau baigné de lumière en souriait
c'est génial
un jour de fête pour les 2300 habitants
de la ville parmi lesquelles des
français comme arthur
ta barbe est complètement gelé il est
étudiant en climatologie il a 23 ans
j'ai en train de geler le soleil ne
chauffe pas du tout ici mais bon on est
content de le voir quand même c'est
juste le rayon du soleil qui font
plaisir à voir là on sait que ça va être
pour de bon et après on file vers les 24
heures de jour continue par le soleil de
minutes ça c'est super excitant de la
nuit polaire au jour sans fin l'ong
urbaine la ville de tous les extrêmes
est devenue une curiosité mondiale
elle est la capitale du svalbard un
archipel norvégien plus proche du pôle
nord que de l'europe
nichée dans une vallée au beau milieu
d'un désert de glace et de neige elle
attire chaque année de plus en plus
l'aventurier des touristes en quête
d'authenticité et de dépaysement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais aussi des étudiants conscience et
des chercheurs venus observer le
dérèglement climatique car longue herben
et la ville qui se réchauffe le plus
vite au monde vous laissez votre frigo
ouvert il est beaucoup plus facile de le
réchauffer et c'est tout l'écosystème
qui est bouleversé les glaces fondent
les rênes meurent de faim et les ours
polaires se rapproche dangereusement de
la ville
alors les habitants s'organisent et
s'équipent tous deux fusils
[Musique]
bien évidemment on va prendre la
décision de sauver la vie humaine est
malheureusement
immersion dans la ville la plus au nord
du monde
en plein coeur de l'ong urbaine
ce bâtiment imposant abrite l'institut
polaire de norvège
climatologues géologue glaciologue une
dizaine de chercheurs travaillent ici
comme jean claude gallet un français de
38 ans
son métier étudie les changements
climatiques sur le terrain et il part
rarement léger
sous vêtements en laine ou coucher un
peu plus épaisse en laine et puis la
veste de scooter qui elle est bien
molletonné et qui est surtout qui
protège beaucoup contre le vent et de
bonnes chaussures oui surtout avec une
très grosse semelle épaisse qui isole
vraiment du sol afin de garder les pieds
au chaud
température extérieure -16 degrés
température ressentie moins 25 quand il
part en expédition le français n'est
jamais seul
aujourd'hui c'est son collègue américain
steve qui l'accompagnent chargée
d'assurer sa sécurité
[Musique]
on est bon oui tout est bon
jean charles doit prélever de la neige
pour l'étudier
pendant qu'ils travaillent steve
surveille les alentours il est les yeux
du chercheur
je surveille qu'amour scolaire n'arrive
pas
comme on est hors de la ville il ya plus
de risques au kazoo j'ai donc un
pistolet d'alarmé pour effrayé l'animal
et dans le pire des cas j'ai mon fusil
si jamais on se fait réellement attaquer
composition densité épaisseur poids de
la neige jean-charles collecte toutes
ces données pour les analyser et mieux
comprendre le réchauffement climatique
ici il est cinq fois plus rapide
qu'ailleurs dans le monde partout les
marques sont visibles
avant et qui le fjord été complètement
gelé avec de la glace est au dessus de
la neige et on pouvait conduire dessus
et avait 50 60 70 centimètres de glace
l'église 20-30 continue d'ajouter ça
fait à peu près une dizaine d'années
depuis 2004 2005 où la glace a vraiment
reculer et à peu près dix ans qu'on peut
plus conduire de motoneige sur la glace
la glace n'existe plus
on cause le réchauffement de l'océan
arctique l'eau n'est plus assez froide
pour se transformer en glace
plus loin le glacier qui surplombe
longue herben lui ne cesse de reculer
d'année en année
sa fonte participe à la hausse du niveau
des mers sur la planète
au delà du paysage la ville elle aussi
porté les stigmates du réchauffement
climatique
on peut voir les fondations et des
bâtiments ça fait chier légèrement
pouvoir aussi un autre bâtiment la f1
est en cours de démolition
normalement le sol était ici geler toute
l'année est donc stable donc on pouvait
construire et c'est ce qu'on faisait
avant construire à même le sol ou avec
des fondations peu profondes à l'heure
actuelle le sol se réchauffe de plus en
plus en profondeur donc les fondations
deviennent instables le la ville est en
chantier permanent à l'heure actuelle on
est en chantier permanent de détruire
des bâtiments reconstruire des nouveaux
bâtiments détruire des bâtiments
stabiliser des bâtiments si on peut les
stabiliser
et les bâtiments qui s'effondre ne sont
pas le seul danger pour les habitants de
l'ong urbaine
la glace de mer et l'habitat naturel de
l'ours polaire mais avec le
réchauffement climatique la banquise
fond des morceaux se détachent et
dérives jusque sur les côtes du svalbard
rapprochant les mammifères de la ville
il y aurait trois mille ours polaire
dans l'archipel aujourd'hui plus que
d'habitants privés de leur nourriture
naturelle les phoques ces prédateurs
cherchent à manger ailleurs
marie en sait quelque chose la jeune
femme de 27 ans habite en plein centre
ville noël dernier de bon matin elle a
fait une rencontre inquiétante
voilà ce que j'ai vu un ours polaire qui
marchent tranquillement sur la route
principale de la ville il traverse un
petit parking et puis il vient jusque
dans la rue piétonne
quand je les ai vus j'ai eu un très
grand pic des trains
en fait j'ai ouvert ma porte j'allais
sortir promener mon chien et là je vois
l'ours donc je rentre à l'intérieur je
dis à mon chien
l'ours a finalement été repoussés hors
de la ville par des voitures et un
hélicoptère de la police locale plus de
peur que de mal pour marie
mais d'autres ont eu moins de chance
en 1995 une femme de 22 ans randonnée
dans le hall barde a été tuée par un
ours polaire tout comme un jeune anglais
de 17 ans en 2011 et en 2018 un guide
allemand à sutout a été blessé
alors depuis quelques années le port
d'armes est obligatoire pour tous les
habitants dès qu'ils sortent de la ville
pour pouvoir se défendre en cas
d'attaqué
encore faut-il savoir comment manier le
fusil qu
avant d'arriver à longueur bonne
jean-charles le glaciologue n'avait
jamais tiré
désormais plusieurs fois par an sessions
d'entraînements obligatoires avec ses
collègues
bon aujourd'hui on va réviser nos bases
pour savoir comment se défendre en cas
d'attaqués d'ours polaires
l'instructeur commence par une partie
théorique quel parti ils vont devoir
viser si un ours attaque
alors il ya plusieurs cibles a touché en
priorité là c'est le coeur et les
poumons
mais aussi sa tête et sa poitrine
sur le côté vous avez aussi les poumons
et le coeur et de ce côté là aussi
il faut que vous essayer de viser juste
et de le tuer sur le coup
pour ne pas qu'ils souffrent
puis place à la pratique
c'est dans son hangar ouvert sur la
montagne que tous les habitants de la
ville après ne tire et
maintenant vous allez tirer en position
debout
je ne sais pas si vous l'avez déjà fait
mais c'est la position la plus pratique
parce que comme ça vous êtes le plus
mobile c'est plus facile de manier le
fusil
se protéger est ce que ça veut dire ça
nous pose bien évidemment problème mais
ça fait partie de la vie ici si on a
décidé de vivre ici et de faire des
études de terrain ici
quelle est la différence entre laisser
votre collègue se faire tuer par un ours
ou tuer un ours
bien évidemment on va prendre la
décision de sauver la vie mais elle est
malheureusement pas de pub
jusqu'à présent jean charles n'a pas
croisé d'ours sur le terrain si c'était
le cas il espère être prêt
alors là on a une balle en plein coeur
super là c'est un peu moyen et là c'est
en dehors de la cible un peu trop bas ce
sont des bons élèves mais ils ont encore
besoin de pratique
des cours de tir les personnes armées en
pleine rue des panneaux pour prévenir de
la présence d'ours et des températures
extrêmes tous les ingrédients sont
réunis à l'ong urbaine pour faire peur
aux touristes pourtant chaque année ils
sont de plus en plus nombreux à visiter
l'archipel du svalbard
et l'osier moufid un couple de jeunes
français sont venus découvrir ce bout du
monde pendant une semaine
tiens le bien sinon il va partir en
courant
au programme des randonnées mais surtout
aujourd'hui une sortie à chiens de
traîneau
[Musique]
il pousse fort celui là et il est
vraiment vite le baril
c'est super regardent ils sont tous en
train de
repartir avec une poire voix couverte va
on sent que c'est vraiment là c'est leur
vide allait partir qu'on
s'essouffle
c'est génial
d'être sûrs que de ma vie
et ouais c'est toi la présente pilotes
graphiques
pour cette balade d'un peu plus d'une
heure le couple à débourser 140 euros
par personne un luxe qu'elodie et moufid
sont bien loin de regretter
[Musique]
c'était super génial on avait envie de
rester encore des heures et des heures
dessus en plus on voyait beaucoup de
gens elle est plutôt proche des animaux
donc
partager ça a vécu ses défenseurs qu'on
n'oubliera pas
les choses les plus simples et les plus
belles que j'ai fait dans ma vie donc
nos prix alexandre song
et l'osier moufid n'ont pas choisi leur
destination de vacances au hasard ils
ont décidé de visiter le svalbard avant
qu'il ne change de visage car ces
paysages envoûtants unique au monde sont
bel et bien menacé en 50 ans la
température moyenne a déjà augmenté de 4
degrés et dc1 domitia qu'elle pourrait à
nouveau se réchauffer de 6 à 8 degrés
[Musique]